good afternoon everyone and welcome to
today's
council meeting um please remind
everyone of some basic housekeeping such
as having your mobile phones
switched off please or put silence and
the emergency evacuation procedure is
out the doors that we came through and
also to the right
of my right of the stage up here so to
begin i'd like to invite
reverend jim edie
thank you hope you can all hear me okay
thank you counselor fitter let us pray
lord we are meeting today to conduct
matters of business from neighborhood
plans
being presented for adoption to motions
regarding parking
and travel we lift the important
business of this council
to you
father we particularly lift to you today
aspects of council work
and decisions that will affect our
planets and local environments
in the book of genesis you charge us
with the responsibility for
and stewardship of our world to wisely
use its resources
and to care and attend to the natural
world
we see around us
lord forgive us as so many of our daily
activities impact the world around us
negatively
lord we give thanks that after many
years of scientific research and
evidence
the damage that human activity is doing
to our home
has finally been brought to public
attention
we give thanks for groups campaigning
and working locally
such as the warwickshire and cotswold
wildlife trusts
and warwickshire climate alliance
along with those people and organized
organizations with
an international voice
lord you call us to love our neighbor as
ourselves
help this council to make decisions and
develop policy
that is workable and will protect
the natural ecosystems and wildlife
we live alongside
father god we lift to you our district
as coveted restrictions
are lifted we particularly lift
to you the vulnerable and those who are
fearful help those in our communities to
respect each other
at this time
we lift the nhs to you we give thanks
that the vaccine
has meant reduced critical cases but
pray for your protection on staff
as restrict restrictions ease
and as a result there is a possibility
of increases
in admissions
we lift our own local nhs foundation
trust to you
and changes and reforms being made
within it
we pray for guidance and wisdom for
decision makers
with these processes
and lord as we reflect on the
disappointing results for many last
nights
we also turn our attention to the darker
side of humanity
to the abuse and violence of some that
has rightly made the headlines today
we give thanks for gareth southgate and
his team
and the esau ethos of justice and
inclusion
that they have held up but lord
help us to speak out in unity against
these injustices
help us as we support those affected by
any sort of abuse whether verbal
physical or domestic
lord we lift those who were victims of
such abuse yesterday
some known and many more unknown
may they know something of your healing
power today
finally father we reflect on the death
of former councillor
chris williams we give thanks for his
life and particularly for his time
serving as a councillor we particularly
lift to you
at this time his family particularly his
wife
carol and son brian
and also close friends and colleagues
jesus as we are reminded by those words
from john's gospel
for god so loved the world that he gave
his only son so that everyone who
believes in him
may not perish but have eternal life
it is through your death and
resurrection that we can have hope for
life beyond the grave
may you give those who mourn chris
williams at this time
and knowledge of your love peace
and comfort
so lord as this meeting continues
guide our hearts and our minds in the
spirit of fairness
right thought and speech impart your
wisdom
upon our activities so that our affairs
may reach
a successful conclusion
thank you for being our source of
guidance today
we ask these things in the name of
christ jesus
amen
thank you um
so now we move to the apologies for um
for absence
so i invite the head of paid service to
report the list of apologies
thank you chairman apologies have been
received from councillors adam
alcock bromage foytick
kendall o'donnell and rolf thank you
thank you very much um item number two
um so i invite
members to make any declarations of
interest at the meeting
and i invite phil grafton
oh hi so i have
i think i have to declare on item 8
because there are projects
included that are in my world and also
item 10
because there is the clifford chambers
and mythical neighborhood development
plan
and i hope i can still talk um
on these items
yes that's that's in order um
councillors
item seven on your agenda which is the
uh fixed some travel payment
um i'm granting a dispensation to all
members to speak and vote on this item
because of the
effect on all counsellors uh in the room
thank you
great thank you um so item number three
uh the minutes
i seek a proposal we've got
i just wanted to ask whether i need to
declare an interest in item 9 the ulster
neighborhood development plan as i'm a
councillor in ulster
i think if this was a document that was
actually determining in some way
individual applications that would be
the point at which you would need to
declare but not in the instance of this
which is
really a strategic document great so um
a proposal for the minutes
please thank you councillor fielding and
the second
council of richards thank you very much
um
so now we move on to items for reference
by the council
and um i'd like to invite the chief
executive
to make any announcements
chairman thank you two announcements
today
council firstly bring to your attention
the unfortunate death of council
previous councillor cam
garrett morgan who represented the
southern ward between
may 1989 and may 2002
the second announcement follows what the
prime minister is going to say
tonight so this is our second stint in
the playhouse and hopefully our last
um so if we do move to step four
as predicted then we will be reverting
for future meetings in elizabeth house
thank you chairman thank you and uh
council jefferson
thank you chairman uh we are now
more or less back to normal in terms of
face-to-face meetings
and i've attended a number uh one of
which was a meeting with the leader of
dudley council
and the leader of warwick district
council in believe it or not warwick
castle
to discuss tourism and other issues i
also attended a meeting with the chamber
of commerce
at long marston and finally i visited
lotus cars
and met with the senior team regarding
inward investment into the district
thanks so i'm moving on to uh
number five so um so i refer to the
death of former councillor chris
williams who is a district councillor
for the farnborough award 1998-2002
fenney copton ward in 2002 2015
and napton and fenney comes award to
2015 to 2019
so council williams also served as
planning and transport
portfolio holder in 2001 to 2004.
local economy and district promotion
portfolio
holder for 2005 2006 and community
services
portfolio holder 2006 into 2009.
so a very very busy dedicated counsellor
um i'd like to invite
group leaders now to address the meeting
if they wish um
but and also be followed by any members
of the council
uh so council jefferson thank you
chairman
i mean there's no doubt about it uh
chris williams
served both the district and the county
with distinction over a long period of
time
some 23 years which is very very
impressive
chris was not someone i knew
particularly well as i only joined the
council in 2015
but nevertheless he struck me as a very
diligent
and effective counsellor thank you chair
the counselor junaid or counselor nigel
rock please
thank you chairman chris williams and i
um represented adjacent wards on this
council for eight years
from 2003 although he served much longer
than i did
as might be expected as members of
different political groupings we had our
disagreements
but we all but we sat together on the
east area planning committee for those
eight years
we're in some fairly thorough
examinations of the issues before us he
and i tended to agree
more often than not we also made common
cause when phenicompton fire station
came under threat of
closure when i returned to the council
in 2019 there had been some boundary
changes
meaning the new ward knapton and fenny
compton was the one i took over from
that
that chris had stepped down from
representing
he was well known across all the
villages in the ward and he continued to
do this job during his long
battle within ill health i think he's
been
one of the longest serving councillors
in the area both at county and district
level
and i'm sure he will have left his mark
for that i express my sympathy
to his family friends and colleagues
thank you chairman
thank you councillor barker
thank you um i was lucky enough to
serve for a little time on this council
with uh
councillor williams but then to uh
when i when i was elected to the county
council he was the whip
and he used to find me absolutely
impossible because i could never get to
meetings on time
um and it didn't matter that i explained
that i had a small child who needed
depositing at nursery or wherever
um he wasn't having it but he and i
became
really really great friends and i
can say this um to this gathering
because i know that you know he would
say this too
both he and i had bowel cancer and so we
joined
we were joined in common cause and
telling equally
rude jokes about our exploits having the
same disease
he was as tough as old boots tougher
than i am and had had so many illnesses
i just couldn't believe it he was an
amazing chap
told the rudest jokes he was an
irratable get to deal with
but i absolutely loved him and i will
miss him greatly
thank you councillor parry
thank you chairman i felt enormously
privileged to be invited to
the funeral and be amongst the 30 guests
attending the service which was quite
magnificent
um particularly in the covid times
chris was very much my mentor when i
joined the district council back in 2014
and was landed into planning and he
helped me hugely
i also happened to work with his wife in
a job share
uh scenario at a local estate agent so
got to know them all very much both
socially
and as councillors and then when i
became elected to the county council
again chris was there um trying to give
me the ins and outs of
how foreign county council operated
terrific sense of humor such
a brave and courageous man and my
sympathies go to
his family at this still very difficult
time
and these very difficult circumstances
thank you chair
thank you councillor mills
thanks mr chairman yes um i first met
chris
uh in 1998 when we both stood as uh
as district councillors um he got
through for fenney
and i didn't for kineton but i always
say to everybody
i came second but it sounds better than
coming last
so i got to know chris um when i got
elected in 2007.
and i've probably told this story before
and some of you have heard this
he had the most horrific accident
arms and legs broken he lost his memory
totally
and when his wife went to visit him
he didn't know her and i mean she gave
him
something like a banana what do i do
with this so we you pick it up and eat
it and he
picked it up and bit into it not knowing
that to peel it
and when he came out of the hospital um
she
took him around the supermarket
describing this as an apple this is an
orange
um this is potato but gradually is uh
his memory came back and they knew he
had something there because he could
count to ten
um but um he gradually regained his his
memory to best he could and will now
work very very hard
uh as a counsellor um
but um and we both like adam myself at
the funeral and he learned so much about
somebody and he was a great athlete um
he actually swam from the isle of wight
to the mainland as a
youngster he was a great
rugby player paid hooker and and had
this amazing life
born in india uh had a pedro graphic
business
um very very interesting guy indeed so
and i know he was um
dedicated to both the district and
county council
thank you mr chairman thank you uh
councillor kettle
um thank you well i was a neighbouring
councillor of chris
um and with his county council hat on he
and i shared
uh a number of parishes um i i won't
repeat what chris
mills council chris mills already said i
was going to refer to his
remarkable recovery from a very severe
um
accident but i would say he was
immensely well prepared as a counselor
his files he produced at any meeting
were lengthy and detailed the reports he
gave
to council set an example to all um
so he was immensely proud of being a
counsellor
and he took his roles very very
seriously um
i didn't know him terribly well as a
person but i do know that he and his
wife
were an absolutely robust team when it
came to canvassing in fact i think his
wife
more so than him um so he was a
um a dedicated counsellor
an example to us all thank you
councillor fielding
thank you chairman um it was through him
that i got
um seconded on to be standing for
election
when the then councillor decided that he
was
going to stand down and there was a
slight panic because it was
in my february march when that happened
and there could be a by-election
um so i got rung up and said would i
like to stand i've been chairman of
radway parish council
but chris will always remain on my my in
my mind for the support he gave
myself his wonderfully lengthy
reports that used to send most people
off to sleep and there was always a vote
let's not
we'll we'll have it on the website
rather than read it out so
um but he was a great man and uh we used
to sit in natter
we both had parents who had lived abroad
when we were sent over to school in this
country so there was a
certain element of friendship between
the two of us online
thank you thank you councillor crump
thank you mr chairman um i used to enjoy
planning committees when
uh councillor williams yeah certainly
mined uh some long tedious evenings uh
far more enjoyable and
he came up with this phrase if it's not
right it's wrong
and it's it's a phrase i still use at
planning committee
he was a great wit a dry sense of humor
and perhaps i think i should be learning
from
rather than my puns but i was taught by
council mills
um i shared napton um
as a county council with him and we were
known as grumpy and grumpy at least i
think that was
unless it was grumpy crumpy i'm not sure
it was a which one was it
uh yes i will certainly miss cancer
williams a great
counselor who got a great sense of humor
which he used to good effect but he was
also very knowledgeable and did a lot of
work
and was certainly very well respected by
his residents and parishes
uh wrestling priest chris and thoughts
and condolences with family and friends
thank you so i now move the following um
that the council notes with regrets the
death of former councillor
chris williams district councillor for
the farmer award fenney thompson ward
and knapton with any compson ward
and extends its sympathy to his family
and friends in their loss
item number six uh pub public
participation uh we haven't received
any questions so moving on to uh item
number seven which is the fix some
trouble payment and i'd invite
council jefferson as leader of the
council to introduce this report
thank you chair this report is about
considering uh reinstating to fix some
travel payment
uh looking at the options available to
counsel
i my suggestion is that we reinstate
the fixed sum travel payment as from the
7th of may when first to first meetings
recommends
that to me gives a very clean edge so
i am proposing the recommendation that
consideration be given as
to whether to fix some sorry
we should reinstate the fixed sum travel
payment
as from the 7th of may when first and
first meetings recommends
okay thank you i now look for a seconder
councillor tony dixon thank you
yeah anyways anyone want to speak on
this this issue no
okay so we've agreed um and we can
confirm that resolution
so um item number eight uh some minutes
the
adoption of the infrastructure funding
statement so i'd like to invite
councillor pemberton
to this to introduce his item
thank you chairman members
the the recommendation here uh is for
the uh council to adopt
the 2020 2021 infrastructure
funding statement uh this is a piece of
work that we must do on an annual basis
it sets out the scope of
the process by which projects which are
brought to this council by various
organizations are assessed and
considered
for um the provision of sill funds
so the the component parts are an
infrastructure list
of projects or type of infrastructure
that would be supported
a section 106 report setting out
standard information
a sill report setting out information on
income and spend for the previous
financial year
and a sil spending protocol the purpose
of this is not for us to consider
the merits or demerits of any particular
project that is on the list this is
about the the
the process by which we will we will we
will address
so for the future for the next year in
2021
and i would uh recommend to cancel that
the
infrastructure funding statement is
therefore adopted
thank you thanks i now look for a
seconder
council of cargo uh counselor junaid
uh just to mention again that it was a
specific request from the overview and
scrutiny committee
that a report on unallocated funds
uh be regularly reported to that
committee
so that we might keep an eye on how that
how the progress is going on those
unallocated funds
thank you councillor pemberton yeah
thank you thank you chairman
and this was raised at cabinet and will
be the subject of a discussion
um with the chair of oven scrutiny
just to ensure that whatever
reporting mechanism is put in place
actually adds some value
basically on the premise that we're not
in control of
the delivery of these projects um so
my uh i think i would be looking as it's
noted in the minute
uh for a conversation with the chair to
understand
uh how uh officers and iron as a
portfolio holder
can provide uh something that actually
adds some value for overview and
scrutiny
um because as i say we do need to uh
support ons in in its work but to
provide it with
the right information and i think that's
the subject of a further discussion
thank you councillor bertogallon yeah i
just wanted to add i'm very pleased to
see
projects which promote active travel
especially cycling
in included in this list and i'm also
very pleased that the meonville pavilion
project has been included
as an important social infrastructure
project thank you
thank you so i can um confirm that
resolution
um item nine so i'd like to
invite council pemberton
thank you chairman item nine is the
ulster neighborhood development plan
which uh went through its referendum on
may the sixth
where the uh the community of ulster
endorsed the plan with a 79.7
yes vote which was 1549 yes votes to 394
no votes on attack turnout for the
ballot of 39.4
um the first thing i would like to say
is to is to
thank the members of the ulster
neighborhood development plan
working group for the hard and diligent
work that they have
undertaken in helping the community of
ulster
to come to a fruition of a neighborhood
development plan
that this council can can now adopt
uh and use as material consideration in
the determination of of planning
applications
i'd also like to thank the members of
the planning
policy team for the work that they have
undertaken
in working alongside the members of
ulster's ndp group
so members the recommendation is that
the
neighborhood development plan which is
appendix one to your papers
is adopted with immediate effect with
the consequence that it becomes part of
the development plan for
stratford-upon-avon districts
thank you thank you i look for a second
council of cargo thank you
switch it
thank you so the motion has been
proposed and seconded are we all in
agreement
with this one counselor junit uh yes i
i i just also wanted to add my thanks i
was part of the
um the the the group that worked on the
neighborhood plan and uh
just want to thank all that team thank
you
um so moving on now to item 10
councillor pemberton
sorry's hold on councillor kessel just
before we move on mr chairman
there's any shots we could turn the
lights up a little bit there are certain
tables which are well lit
uh but council shenzhen and i i can see
and uh
canceled harvey but we're almost in
darkness
yeah i'm sure the team can have a look
at that but we'll we'll crack on uh with
item 10.
that's that way we can't see them i am
afraid we're getting shakes to the head
from the back
counselor kettle that there is a table
which is particularly well lit
on that side if you want to turn to the
right hand side of the chamber
i'm sorry we can't do anything about the
lighting in the in in here today sorry
thank you chairman uh the next item is
the illmington neighborhood development
plan
uh which again went to referendum on the
sixth of may
uh where the local uh community uh sorry
council hamilton um we've skipped the
clifford chambers
i do indeed yes i apologize
starting again no one noticed a thing
so clifford chambers and bill cut
took its neighborhood development plan
to referendum on the 6th of may
and that plan was endorsed by the
community with a 91.6
yes vote 218 votes in favor of the plan
to 20 votes against uh and the ballot
generated a huge turnout for this type
of thing of 57.2 percent
and so the community at clifford
chambers and milka are to be commended
for
for engaging with the process um so
i would like to thank the members of the
clifford chambers and milk
milk neighborhood development plan group
for their work in bringing this plan
to fruition and again repeat my thanks
to the officers who have worked
alongside the group
um to ensure that this plan is now uh in
a position where subject to uh the
decision of this council can be adopted
with immediate effect
so that it becomes part of the
development plan for stratfor upon avon
district
uh and i commend that uh to to members
thank you
thank you and i'll call for a second
counselor together
i'd like to second uh the
council of pemberton i also like to
thank all those involved in the making
of the plan
lots of important work has gone into
this policy document
and this can now shape a future
development for the parish
thank you thank you um so the motion has
been proposed and seconded and
we are all are we all in agreement yep
great so um item 11 council council of
pemberton
spoiler alert this is now illmington
neighborhood development plan
thank you the uh chair um again uh
another referendum on the 6th of may
where the local community
endorsed the illington neighborhood
development plan
with a resounding 90.8 yes vote
of 325 votes to 33 votes against
are on a ballot generated of 60 and
again
two neighborhood development plans with
high turnouts which i think
is a testament to to both groups ability
to engage their
their communities in shaping the the
local priorities
so again i would like to thank the
the members of the illmington
neighborhood development plan group for
their work in bringing
the plan to fruition and of course our
officers working alongside them
members the recommendation to cancel is
that the illmington neighborhood
development plan
is adopted with immediate effect and so
that it therefore becomes part of the
development plan for stratford-upon-avon
district and i look for a second er
thank you thank you i will second that i
think elmington illington
development plan they've done a
fantastic job with it and um
yeah it's really really fantastic so
well done to them um item
12 uh the mode that motion has been
proposed and seconded and
are we all in agreement great yep thank
you um item 12
uh council of badminton thank you very
much
uh chair uh and this was the the fourth
of the referendum held on the sixth of
may
uh and then absent on the hill
neighborhood development plan
was put before its community
and the community endorsed a plan with a
78.3
yes vote which was 458 votes
to 127 votes against and again you know
a very good turnout
at 57.4 percent for napton on the hill
um again this is a a group of dedicated
people
uh who have worked uh to help uh
the the future for uh the development in
their community and
engaged local residents effectively uh
in in that process and i would like to
commend them for their work in bringing
the plan to fruition
and equally once again to thank members
of the planning policy team
to bring the development plan forward so
members of council the recommendation is
that the nation on the hill neighborhood
development plan
is adopted with immediate effect with
the consequence that it becomes part of
the development plan for spot for the
panavan district
uh and i seek a second before that thank
you chair
kels larocque uh thank you chairman i
would like to
second that resolution and uh uh echo
council of pemberton's words about the
hard work that's gone into this one and
i'm sure
all the other enabled development plans
and uh i am sure and hope that both the
officers
and the planning committees will
recognize that when we come to planning
decisions
thank you chairman thank you so the
motion has been proposed and seconded
are we all in agreement agreed
thanks um so moving on to item
13. um so the questions have been
published on the council's website
um so we've got 17 questions have been
received and these have been circulated
to you all on a separate sheet
um all members ask questions when i have
the
opportunity to ask one supplementary
question councillor riley do you have a
supplementary question
for question one
thank you and question two
thank you councillor junaid
uh the last part of my question was uh
has not been answered
and it is would the portfolio support an
overview and scrutiny review of the
housing waiting list
provision of affordable housing and the
relationships with housing associations
in our district
and i have been in conversation with the
chair of
overview and scrutiny committee who is
um
open to that suggestion
thanks councillor barker um i'm
very happy for ovue and scrutiny to um
review
i i think that reviewing the housing
waiting list itself is a bit dubious
because of
because that's people obviously the
provision of affordable housing in the
relationship with housing associations
is something you can look at but those
are certainly things that
i do on a day-to-day basis furthermore
the housing strategy when it comes
forward again
we'll be looking at um home choice plus
in particular which i think is what a
lot of this is referring to
so it is in train but uh help from osc
would be most useful
thank you uh counselor purchase aguela
do you have a supplementary question
um yes so i'm i'm just a bit worried
that
the the figure of 250 is is
obviously an estimate and apparently
there can be an accurate understanding
of how many unlicensed properties there
are
and i wonder whether there are criteria
in place to know that
because obviously i think this is
something that we should know because
how how do they enforce um
um you know license and so on so i don't
know whether there are
there is a process in place where you
can tell us
how many properties uh in um multiple
occupation are unlicensed
thanks councillor barker i'm about to go
a bit
donald rumsfeld here about known
unknowns and unknown unknowns i think
because if we don't know
that a an hmo is unlicensed
we probably don't know there's an hmo
there in the first place so with the
best will in the world because this is
related to private landlords
um this is the best we can do
and that is where it's summed up there
are certainly
methods potentially that could be used
but we would have to check them against
gdpr
thank you uh councillor cleve do you
have a supplementary question
yes thank you um thank you for the
information it's really interesting to
see that can i just ask with only four
key workers at least that's
the quick glance full key workers
currently registered
in the building do we know why there the
uptake for this is
blue blueprint scheme is so low
councillor parry thank you and thank you
councillor klee for your interest in
this
um particular project i can't be
specific on that
but of course the issue with the key
workers is that the key workers doesn't
just
include nurses and farmers and policemen
and teachers
it also applies to people working
locally
so because stratford they qualify on a
key worker status
whether perhaps they work in hospitality
because that is a local need
so they are a key worker plus obviously
if if an apartment
has been vacant for so many weeks then
it becomes
an open issue for people outside the
area
but i think the problem is the key
workers aren't defined because of
gdpr etcetera onto specific professions
but key workers are more widely
recognized across a whole range of
disciplines that have a specific
local connectivity of importance to
the area thank you so um council adam
uh isn't here so we're back to
councillor cleve
uh thank you this isn't it's kind of a
question so apologies for this
i mean i just first say thank you to
karen stanley for sitting with me
and going through my question she did an
incredible job
and i just really appreciate their time
could i also just ask
based on this these answers that all
members are fully aware of it and
let them ensure their residents know how
to report crimes
um especially the non-emergency crimes
and
are aware of the community trigger
program as well so if we can all ask
that that would be
very much appreciated thank you thank
you counselor kettle do you have
anything to add i'm really sorry
counselor please i couldn't quite hear
could you repeat your question in
view as well as possible it wasn't
really a question it was thanking karen
stanley for her time on that but as
i think you said it in um when you
introduced the training the other day is
ensuring that we all
let our residents know about how to
report a crime especially the
non-emergency ones and make sure that
it's a priority
so that they get the stats um yeah i
mean the the
information is of course published in
the um uh
the most recent uh cabinet papers i
think the june cabinet papers
uh where the priorities are published um
and clearly they do
they do change but from year to year um
but all i can say is the uh the team
uh at stratford which is not a large
team it can
consists of um um karen stanley and her
force of team leaders really is a very
small team
so um but i think what they are that
they are trying their best
thank you thank you sorry just yeah
that's i was thanking them for all their
hard work
well thank you both um councillor
pertico do you have a supplementary
question
yes i do so i'm very concerned
about the high number of rejections um
for
um this particular scheme and
and i believe is contributing to the
failure or one of the government's key
policies to combat the spread of the
virus so
i would like to know whether the
portfolio holder um assert
the progress of the local government
associations
complain to government about the strict
criteria thank you casper
that's aimed at people i don't think
we've got that far with the questions
yet
mr chairman yeah
yeah we're up to date um i don't agree
with councillor pertagella because this
council
is paid out over 50 percent of
the self-isolation payments and i would
point you to the answer
the original answer the question which
says that this is a prescriptive
national scheme we don't have discretion
so
we pay out per the regulations
on behalf of the government that are
doing our level best
i think that self you need to you
perhaps could understand that
self-isolation is only one part
of the whole and as you will probably
hear at five o'clock
uh today self-isolation will be
something that is
going to be changing thank you
the counselor fragile do you have a
supplementary question
um i just feel that this is an area that
perhaps the district and the county
might actually take a little further i
have had one or two cases recently where
um this is this is quite an issue where
people in their 40s and early 50s having
long-term illnesses or
ms or progressive conditions find it
incredibly difficult
to find to find the housing that they
need so i would be looking for
looking to have some conversations in
the future thank you
thank you councillor barker i'm really
glad you've raised this one councillor
frankly because
this morning i was re-contacted by
someone who said after the elections he
wanted to talk to me about
disability campaigning and this is this
is someone who's found himself disabled
um uh under extraordinary circumstances
um and he is very very keen um
to get lobbying so i i have a personal
interest
um from one of my own residents um in
getting involved in this and i do think
that there are
um lacunae in the uh
in the schemes as they exist at present
and
i i see no reason for not uh pressing
ahead with it but
uh please join the course
thank you uh councillor for ashley again
do you have any supplementary questions
i'll follow this in another place thank
you thank you
uh councillor ian bradley do you have a
supplementary question
thank you i was a bit surprised that
this particular project that was
mentioned
didn't include the identify
identification of
growth zones because i'm sure everyone
in this council is looking forward to
seeing where the growth zones will be
so i should be interested as to when the
project
is coming up about the growth zones
thank you councillor pemberton thank you
thank you
chairman i'm not at all surprised the
white paper hasn't been
published we haven't actually got to a
point whether
where actually we know that there are
going to be growth zones
the question is around the i.t system to
support gis
so unless counselor fragile knows
something i don't
i'm not really sure i can give him much
more
thank you um i don't have a
supplementary question uh councillor
foreman
no thank you chair
councillor richards no thank you chair
and councillor mills yeah thank you
chair
wonderful thank you everyone um so
questions to the leader
can i now invite questions to the leader
of the council
counselor cargo
have a new mic plays for councillor
cargill or a replacement
oh thanks john thank you
sorry about that that's better
stratford and warwick districts have
recently seen a number of travelers
descend
on some of our open spaces including
football and rugby pitchers
these illegal encampments often are from
a
violent but minority of the traveller
community
cause damage vandalism littering and
frequently defecation of the playing
fields
rendering them unplayable the cleanup
costs are significant for small clubs
and i can see some either failing or
racking up huge debts
stratfor district council in the process
of preparing a gypsy traverse pd
can the leader assure me that due
account will be taken
in limiting where possible such illegal
intrusions and how to remove travelers
as quickly as possible
and how we can help our communities hit
in this way
thank you thank you councillor cargill
i don't know how passionately you feel
about this particular issue
uh i would point out that these are
illegal
and they take some time to actually
remove
i would say that not all travelers
behave in this way
uh the illegal encampments
gives rise to a complex situation
there needs to be a coordination across
a number of different bodies not just
the district council
so obviously the police are heavily
involved and it's up to the government
as well
to actually really set the ground rules
and on that i understand there's
currently a bill going through
parliament
which would make trespass a criminal
offence
that would give the police powers to
serve a sec section
61 notice on such illegal encampments
much quicker and i think that's a
reminder
that a crime does need to take place
before the police connect
and we do need to remember that uh
i would say though that i think on this
whole issue
of gypsies and travelers there probably
does need to be
a much more fundamental review to
address
all the complex issues around this
particularly fraught issue
thank you counselor junaid
um i've got a couple of if you don't
mind um both slightly related to each
other
virtually all kovit 19 regulations that
are enforced by councils
relating to businesses will be removed
after july the 19th
the local government association is
raising concerns that it will be
difficult for councils
to enforce guidance on risk assessments
uh
under various um legal acts
can the leader assure me that stratfor
district council staff will be able to
operate safely
after july the 19th that is one question
the other question is slightly related
if you don't mind i'll follow on
which is that the number of delta
variant covid19
has risen across the uk by over 54
000 in the last week alone a 32 percent
increase
and although the rises in this district
are less i know that a significant
number of students have been affected in
the last week
would the leader assure me that the
council
is going to be able to operate uh in the
weeks and months to come
and that any face-to-face meeting in
elizabeth house will be kept under
review
as we go forward
thank you councillor junaid i think one
of the
issues on this is that the law will have
changed
and that makes it very difficult to
actually enforce
an awful lot of the things you suggest
so
can we actually enforce um
the wearing of masks for example social
distancing
assuming that what was said last week is
carried through to today
i think we would find that very
difficult we have to operate within the
legal framework
thank you councillor dixon
thank you chairman uh
from the government dot uk statistics
to date over 5 million positive tests
have been confirmed
this represents about seven and a half
percent of the population
i appreciate that some unlucky people
may get covered
more than once especially any new strain
despite the very successful rollout of
the vaccination program
which is still progressing there has
been a death rate of about three percent
of those testing positive does the
leader
have any opinions on the longer term
impacts
of kovid 19. thank you chairman
sorry i think actually the long-term
impact
the mic keeps switching off
i think if we if we actually look at the
impact of
curving 19 there are obviously going to
be
impacts of uh
the long term covid
that could well be significant because
the number of people
involved in that could run into hundreds
of thousands
we've already seen the impacts on the
nhs
where there are now over five million
operations
which are queuing up you put those two
together the long covered and the
operations queuing up
that puts severe stress on the nhs which
is going to take
years to actually overcome
uh i think also there are going to be
some very long-term behavioral impacts
of kelvin 19
which at the moment i would suggest are
somewhat
unclear but we're already seeing two of
them come through
one in a reluctance to use public
transport
which actually means the public
transport is going to need an awful lot
of subsidy
the second one that is already coming
through is
a reluctance of a lot of people to
return full-time to offices
that's going to have some knock-on
consequences for the
occupational offices and presumably
the value of offices i won't even go
into what impact that might have on
pension schemes but it could be quite
significant
the other impact which is coming through
very strongly
is actually on high streets
we've already seen an awful lot of shops
uh
closed i think this process is far from
over
not least because businesses have
borrowed about 75 billion
that has to be paid back and
i suspect we will see the high street
retrench
further come february march next year
the final really big impact of kovid
actually is what it has done to
government debt which now runs at a mere
2.2 trillion
fortunately given very low interest
rates this is manageable
however should interest rates rise that
could prove to be
a bit of a problem if you actually look
at things in the round
we've had two once in a century crises
in 12 years we should really hope
we don't get a third in the next decade
thank you councillor crump
thank you mr chairman um it's really
it's a
almost a joint one for myself and
council the rock and i think it's
not in agreement hopefully um
in our part of the district we've had
several water pipe bursts
causing significant disruption to our
residents in schools
and it is it particularly affects the
vulnerable especially those who
use water for medical conditions
um
certainly we feel the southern trent
need to invest more uh in its
infrastructure
and certainly we are we are very
concerned
about the lack of communication around
these verses
um because it's almost chinese whispers
and it's very difficult to
make them hold them to account unlike
councillors unlike councils
we are pretty contactable and sometimes
you have to sit in a queue or
go through facebook or for several hours
before you get
through to somebody and then you get
contradictory remarks from them
but if you speak to someone else so
in light of the news south works your
local plan
council rock and i would like some
reassurance that the water companies
and utility companies can cope with any
further developments
particularly in the east of the district
so our vulnerable vulnerable residents
in that part of the district are not
suffering adversely
thank you
thank you councillor trump
i have to say one of one of my very
strong views
is that we've under-invested in
infrastructure
for decades and i think it's beginning
to bite
very hard now that there are more and
more houses being built in the district
i would wholeheartedly endorse
that when we create the new south
auditor plan
we really do make sure that the utility
companies can deliver
uh i think it is not only water where
there is a particular problem there is
also a problem with electricity
that's very well flagged on water in
particular
i think we need to bear in mind the
implications of climate change
because rainfall could be
heavier and there could be droughts
so water supply could actually become
really really critical
so i fully agree with everything you've
said councillor crump and i think the
interesting thing is
in holding seven trent water to account
uh i will check with the chief exec
exactly how we may be able to be more
proactive on that
because it is not right that uh public
utilities
even though they are now private
companies should not be held
more firmly to account
thank you councillor fielding
thank you council of fielding uh
i think the long-term impacts of the
world shakespeare center we're proposing
should be very substantial i'm not sure
that there's exact clarity on what they
will be
but nevertheless they will be extremely
significant
in 2019 tourism generated
half 500 million for the
district supported around 9 000 jobs
and many businesses and livelihoods are
dependent on tourism
i think one of the things that many
people may not realize
is tourism is a competitive industry
and in all honesty i think we have under
invested in tourism
in the recent past and
just pick up a point on that where i
think far too many people
actually believe economic growth happens
automatically it doesn't it really does
have to be worked for
and the leading times on some things at
five or ten years or even more
certainly if we look at the world
shakespeare center
it will probably be at best 2026.
before it is fully operational
so the results aren't going to be seen
for a number of years
but in the short term one of the things
it really does do is it sends a strong
signal to anyone thinking of investing
in the district
investing in the high street that we
really are
open for business we mean business and
we've got a bright future
it's also a project i think of regional
and national significance
and we need to think about it as such
how much work went into it
a hell of a lot of work went into it the
final document was about 120 pages
the number of meetings that were held
and the iterations backwards and
forwards to improve it
were absolutely substantial and we were
working in partnership
with the birthplace trust one should
never
ever underestimate the amount of work
that
actually has to go in to submissions on
some of these projects
and i think that's really important
because it means you can't just clutch
at
every opportunity that's going because
in a lot of cases
unless you meet the criteria then
you're not going to stand much chance on
this one we think we stand
a really good chance and we have a lot
of strong support
from an awful lot of influential people
and that
absolutely matters so
i hope that's answered your question
counselor fielding
thank you councillor rock uh
thank you chairman this is uh now as
councillor trump's asked this question
this is in the nature of a supplementary
and i agree with everything he said and
everything that the leader said in
response
um but uh the chief executive and i had
a
a an interchange about our seven trent
short-term problems which
team after today and i very nearly
didn't get here today because of
the public ringing me up about the
second major burst
in the southam area i think as well as
looking at the strategic
long-term planning aspects of
infrastructure
we do need some mechanism of being able
to get hold of these people in the
in the um utilities to be able to do
and to deal with them because i've been
hanging on the phone
as as councillor crump for a long time
trying to be able to get
hold of somebody that needs it we don't
seem to have a system
for counsellors in between blue lights
and um something that's quite modest
so i'm just wondering uh leader if we
could actually have a look
at something that's actually quite
difficult but some sort of back door to
get into these places
to alert them to what's going on in the
community
which they don't seem to know in my
experience as well as finding out what
they're doing about it thank you leader
uh thank you i think thank you
councillor rock
i have to say i've had issues in my ward
with seven trent in this case it was a
big hole in the road
which caused no end of problems i think
you're absolutely right
i think we will take it away we'll look
at this and we will try
to find a we're in to seven trent
i think we're probably also going to
have to work in conjunction with the
county council on this
because if we do a two-pronged approach
it
might generate more and better results
but i fully agree with what you say
i think what we are suffering from now
is if i may say so decades of under
investment in the water infrastructure
which goes back to the response i gave
to one of the
questions earlier and we're going to pay
a price for it
but that does not mean we should not be
seen
to be holding seven trent to account
thank you councillor curtis
sorry about that thank you chair um
regarding the southwestern relief road
warrior county council has stated they
cannot say
where the funding for this project would
come from and
currently the district council cannot
identify any funding stream
likely to cover the additional 90
million pounds required for this
two and a half mile stretch of road
for many years residents lives have been
blighted by the uncertainties attached
to this approach
attached to this proposal which is
unaffordable
ill-conceived and where it proceed
will be environmentally damaging
destroying much valued and irreplaceable
wildlife habitats
and creating additional pollution and
congestion
as reported in the herald again this
week the council is
quote serious about tackling climate
change
does the leader agree with the stratford
residence action group
the planning permission for this project
should now be withdrawn
or at the very least with the leader
commit to a full review
of this project thank you chair
i think one of the first points to make
councillor curtis is that
it is not up to us to withdraw the
planning application
it's up to the developer uh
i think at the moment as well there is
an awful lot of work to do in the long
marston
area to actually identify
how that development may be taken
further so at the moment i wouldn't
particularly wish to comment further on
that
on the southwest relief road issue
council fleming
yes thank you um the uh
the recent sort of national sort of
volatility in uh
in politics is is sort of showing up at
the moment
and i just wonder what the uh what the
leaders view is
on the results of the ambition by
election
thank you councillor fleming well i
think there's a couple of interesting
points in the amisham
uh one is the liberal democrats appear
to have a national policy of supporting
hs2
locally however they opposed it
i do suppose it's perfectly reasonable
to build a new railway and have a bit
missing
i'm not sure it's terribly practical and
i'm not sure it's a good way to run a
railway
so you know one's got to take that into
account
on a serious point it demonstrates i
think that
if you feel you've no chance of actually
having to put
promises into action you can make
whatever promises you like locally
uh there's a sense in which
the lack of join up in the railway is a
metaphor for the fact that there's not a
lot of joined up thinking in the liberal
democrat
camp and they don't seem to learn the
lessons from 2010
when they made promises on student fees
they couldn't deliver
it's very important to actually
learn the lessons and make promises you
can deliver
planning was another issue raised
during the election and it's actually a
very very serious
point and it's come up already this
afternoon
there's talk about how many houses we
need
and where we need them and i think
that's the critical
critical question where are they going
to be built
i'll be honest one of my real personal
concerns
um about where we may build houses
chairman if i made sure
i'm sorry leader um during this session
um questions to the leader uh one of the
rules that we have is that it must be
about
the work of the council okay
does that mean that question is not
allowed
as i recall the question it didn't
connect anything
in particular with the work of the
council that's
correct okay then uh so moving on to
councillor harris please
thank you chair good afternoon everyone
it's nice to see you all face to face
and without masks
um i'm sorry i'm going to take you back
to the topic that was raised by council
iraq
and councillor crump um i think this
strength in unity and it's pleasing to
hear this afternoon quite a few of us
are concerned around
infrastructure it's about six months or
more ago i raised this issue with
um westminster with jeremy wright
unfortunately there's a selective
deafness down in westminster and i don't
mean that unkindly i think this is a
communication barrier
because what we were trying to convey to
them was not understood
by the staff in the office and i think
there's a combination of things that
cause that barrier
and that needs revisiting because reply
we got back they certainly didn't
understand
what we said to them and as maybe you
might not think i'm very eloquent i
think jeremy wright is
but that point is our mps are really
concerned around the infrastructure
issue
and i think if you're going forward with
the south warwickshire local plan
and unity with our parishes and
residents us as a district council on
how we manage that and respond going
forward
i'm pleased to hear leader you say about
county about
the rest of the area or in isolation
of holding these utilities to account to
ensure they're going to deliver
for us going forward and i think that's
an important part of the south walks
your local plan
and what we're doing to go forward and i
just wanted to say that and thank you
everyone this afternoon
i think actually councilor harishiri is
a very valid point
because there is no doubt about it there
are issues
with utilities and infrastructure
thank you thanks we've got about five
minutes left of this section but next up
we've got councillor gradually
uh thank you may i just thank mr grafton
for his intervention
on that question um which i believe was
a bit of a political plant
my question on a statement made at
a recent election was disallowed quite
rightly
because it was concerning the county
council and i think that question that
was actually asked
should have been rejected as rapidly as
mine was
thank you okay thank you councillor
curtis
uh thank you yes following on from that
i was going to pick up the
leader's comments about promises made by
the liberal party
but and i was going to refer um him to
promises made perhaps by 40 or 40 new
hospitals by
prime minister johnson but clearly that
is disallowed so i won't make that point
thank you everyone for for these non
questions that we have here at the
moment
um can we please try and stay on on
topic i know that first question
shouldn't really happen but let's um
let's crack on so accounts the rock
it was a point of order actually
chairman but i didn't like to interrupt
proceedings
so presumably council fleming's question
won't be minuted
as it didn't happen because it was out
of order would i be correcting
and that i'm sure and mr grafton will
give us advice
yes that would be the advice thanks
councillor putzkel
yeah um i want to join councilors
council crump and council
rock in their concerns with
our infrastructure problems and in
particular um
seven trends but also russia county
council infrastructure my word as a
repeated incidence of fluvial
and pluvial flooding but also sewage in
gardens and homes
so um and i understand that we need to
liaise and and also have a channel of
communication with seven trend
but what is the responsibility of this
council
in relation to planning
and ensuring that any new development as
the right infrastructure and
infrastructure that can sustain
new development thank you
that's an interesting question
councillor pertigalla
um i'm not exactly sure and other people
probably know better than me
but i'm not exactly sure that when it
comes to infrastructure
uh the planning system is as joined up
as it needs to be
i think one of the problems actually is
that you get individual developments
and all they need do is actually
consider
the infrastructure needed for that
individual development
the knock-on consequences i don't think
are as fully considered as they need to
be and i think that is a weakness
i've come across that particularly on
traffic
and roads and i'm absolutely sure it
will apply
with equal force to drains
thank you squeezing one question we're
running out of time we've got cancer
wally hoggins
as well that's okay you can't say
hoggins
yes thank you could the chairman please
uh not chair leader please could you
tell me uh there are grand plans for the
gateway project and riverside project
could the leader tell me please
how much further forward we are in
securing funding for these ambitious
projects
as i am concerned at the loss of face
for this council if these projects
don't progress further due to lack of
funding thank you
well the riverside project has funding
that was uh
allocated both by the council by the lep
and by the town trust
uh on the gateway project
the application for funding has just
been made
great thank you everyone uh so moving on
now to item 15
the notice of motion update for the over
65's parking permit so please my invites
council ian shenson to speak
thank you chair i'm over here
um i'm happy to to clarify the situation
with regards to the substantive
part of this motion the crux of this
notice of motion are in paragraphs four
to six
on page 41 of your papers that begins
i have been contacted by a number of
volunteers
i reviewed the youtube recording of the
cabinet meeting on the 7th of june
and also downloaded a transcript of the
uh
of the meeting and in my opinion there
are enough
references to volunteers to demonstrate
that the matter
had been debated fully effectively by
allowing the debate and consideration of
the whole proposal
to run for over 22 minutes my feeling is
that the point raised in
paragraphs four to six of the motion
have been considered adequately
and whilst volunteers and volunteering
weren't stated specifically in the
recommendations
at that cabinet meeting it was implied
that the points that have been raised in
this motion have
and had been considered and debated and
therefore
i asked council to reject this motion
i am happy to clarify any points
regarding the motion
but not the wider issue of permits which
is not the subject of this motion
and preferably at the end of any
speeches by members
thank you chairman thank you okay moving
on to
item 16. we've got motions on notice the
south watcher
nhs foundation trust uh just to clarify
this motion will be referred to the
cabinet
for consideration and reports without
debates
and finally
okay uh moving on to item 17. is there
any
urgent business i don't believe there
are any items of
urgent business so the meeting is now
closed
you